alright meltem we've got a lot to get
through yeah we we had a great warm-up
before we turned on the recording so
should be fun let's go over real quick
for people who don't know just your
background and then we can dig into all
of the controversial ideas that I'm sure
you're excited to talk about I don't
think they're controversial they're just
you know thoughtful I hope but we can
debate the merits of that so look I
don't want to be boring so I math in
finance background started my career in
the oil and gas industry during the
onshore shale boom have seen what
irrational bubbles look like from the
inside of some of the world's largest
corporations focused primarily on oil
and gas M&A oil and gas strategy and
then decided to go as a consultant
decide to go in-house at Exxon Mobil
worked for the treasurer of the
corporation there and got to sort of see
the inner workings of which at the time
the world's largest corporation which is
really interesting learned a lot there I
went to business school at MIT did a lot
of work there on kind of the FinTech
start-up wave that started around 2012
2013 got into the venture space and
really just saw so many interesting
problems in venture with incentives
between investors and entrepreneurs had
been bitten by the Bitcoin bug and then
met Barry Silbert he'd been working on
this idea called digital currency group
joined him in 2015 to build that out
spent three years there took the firm
from 20 portfolio companies 220 built a
bunch of great businesses did a lot of
really interesting things and also was
there really for the move from Bitcoin
only to enterprise blockchain then to
tokens and now it's back to blockchains
via security tokens so it's been
interesting being a part of that
evolution and really being involved in
many different parts of the ecosystem
now what I do is I'm at coin shares
which is a digital asset management
business I'm really focused on building
the next generation of financial
products and services for retail
investors institutional investors and
most importantly the crypto space we
need to start bringing more
institutional asset management
principles into this industry
to really make it credible in an
investable asset class and it needs to
be done in a way that is kind of true to
the principles of crypto but also
incorporates the last 150 years of
knowledge around corporate finance
behavioral finance incentives etc
absolutely what um what originally drew
dab it coin what why Bitcoin yeah the
original draw to Bitcoin was I needed to
send a transaction and I needed to send
it to a market where there was no real
banking infrastructure my family's from
Turkey originally and I looked at a
bunch of different options and one of my
friends like Oh have you heard of
Bitcoin and so I went on Reddit and I
went to our slash Bitcoin and I was like
wow there's a lot to unpack here this is
wild it's weird I had to then get
bitcoins so I pinged my brother who you
know he and I grew up playing video
games together he's a programmer and a
developer so he's always kind of on the
bleeding edge of these things and he's
like yeah local bitcoins calm so I went
on local bitcoins and I met someone in a
parking lot and it felt like a drug deal
but it was a big coin deal which was
pretty exciting and from there just the
more I started learning the more
interested I became luckily in grad
school I had a lot of free time I was at
MIT where there was a lot of work going
on on campus with students who are you
know mining in their dorm rooms some
students got sued by the state of New
Jersey for running an illegal lottery
because they were running a Bitcoin
faucet so just really fun really
interesting and then the whole crypto
anarchist thing just add an extra layer
of interest I never really thought about
the relationship between money power
politics and societal structure and
citing for me that was really a moment
where I started to just become a lot
more aware of what was happening in the
world and the implications of changing
the structure of how how many works